[Music]
country superstar Miranda Lambert who
recently released her incredible seventh
studio album wild card is voicing her
support for the lgbtq+ community
[Music]
in a new interview with pride source
miranda spoke about attending her very
first pride event in june alongside her
gay brother Luke Miranda said when he
was giving me permission to post about
it we both cried because it was such a
big moment when Miranda was asked about
supporting Luke when he came out to her
she said her brother is way cooler and
added I support him 100% in whatever he
does Miranda also said she now realizes
the importance of using her voice I see
now talking about it why it's a big
moment for other people because it was a
big moment for us too so I'm just glad
that he was okay with that and that we
could share that moment and be
supportive of each other
no matter what we are doing or who we
are and of course Miranda support was
hit with some backlash about that
Miranda said I don't understand why
people have time to get on social media
and be negative I think they should get
a hobby or a job or both so I just don't
let those affect me but I also know that
if you're polarizing you must have an
impact can't be loved by everybody so I
try to take the good and run with that
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
as a member of the lgbtq+ community
people are often shocked that I'm a huge
country fan but I worked in the country
music industry for over ten years
Miranda has always been an absolute
favorite country artists of mine
I hope Miranda showing support will help
other country stars who I know support
the lgbtq+ community speak out because
their voices matter and can have a huge
impact on the queer community so how do
you feel about Miranda Lambert's showing
her support for the lgbtq+ community why
do you think we're friendly country
artists are afraid to speak out and show
their support what do you think of
Miranda's latest album wild card I love
it it's pretty bitchin let me know in
the comments below and don't forget to
subscribe to ET Canada's YouTube page
[Music]
you